hey everybody
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message and today
is july 29th 2021
it's my sister talia's birthday tal if
you're watching
happy birthday if you're not watching
i'll try to remember to text you later
but i'm a very busy guy happy birthday
love you all right uh
guys as always do me a favor share
subscribe notification bell
the whole shebang we're on youtube who
knows how long we'll be on youtube for
they don't seem to like us very much
and i don't know if you know about this
but censorship is coming
more and more and more and if they don't
like you on
one website they probably don't like you
on another that's a little plug for
reubenreport.locals.com because i'm
always going to be there and i own all
of it and we're spinning it off
for all kinds of other people as you
guys know i am going off the grid after
tomorrow it is a big day
i will be announcing the pre-sale for my
next
book i will make a couple uh
announcements related
to locals and then i disappear for a
month and in normal years it's like ah
you know
maybe something political happened maybe
there's a hurricane or something
this is a particularly odd year where
it's like will the president be alive
will his head explode i pop out will uh
you know the communists fully take over
will california you know crack and be
no longer part of the united states who
the hell knows but uh this is exactly
why i go off the grid and i'm psyched to
do it and really more than anything else
tomorrow
i just can't wait to share the the title
of the book and i'm gonna sign
every single copy that we sell tomorrow
all the copies that we sell at our
locals community will be signed and
numbered so those are absolutely
exclusive to locals the signed and
numbered copies
if you're a member at locals
report.locals.com and then we're going
to do a live stream normal time here
tomorrow at 11 a.m pacific and every
single copy
that gets sold uh will get signed
tomorrow we got three stories for you
uh covid it's back baby or at least it's
back in terms of the media and our
politicians
pushing it on us most normal people are
just kind of going through their
day-to-day and ignoring these fools at
this point who got everything wrong the
entire time and keep
getting everything wrong and i'm sort of
at the point at this point where it's
like if you want to wear a mask
and get jabbed every month and stay in
your basement if that's what half the
country wants to do
then great i just can't do it but if
that's what you guys want to do and
maybe once a week we'll come and we'll
throw some fish heads down there and you
can eat the fish heads
that would be just great uh but yeah
there's so we got a whole bunch of
coveted stuff that's uh going on
including that just in the last like
literally like three minutes
uh apparently dc is now recommending
indoor mask mandates again
and the question is okay so you you put
out a mass mandate but like
so what do you have to do it like what
happens to people who don't do it these
people only have authority if we keep
giving it to them
uh then elizabeth warren who is a
ridiculous fake
indian who once pretended to be native
american to get a job
uh she is backing gavin newsom uh in his
recall election here and she's really
terrible and he's really terrible we're
going to show you the ad and it's
just full of lies just lie much like
elizabeth warren lies about everything
you know demanding that your kids go to
public school
while her kids of course go to private
and charter schools amongst a gajillion
other lies
and then finally speaking of dc crime is
exploding
and you guys know it's exploding in a
ton of our progressive-run cities
but now the dc mayor you know what she
wants to do you're not going to believe
it guys now that
she defunded the police and attacked the
police and a lot of police retired
and decided who needs the headache now
she wants more police
who could have seen it coming crazy
stuff crazy stuff uh but all right let's
start with all this covid
lunacy first here is some videotape
of ridiculous marxist new york city
for now mayor bill de blasio on msnbc
and as i often say
scratch a progressive find a fascist
and look i'm a parent my kids went to
new york city public schools
if my kids were going to school in
september i would be running to get them
vaccinated right now and
and like was said a moment ago you we
used to do this
as parents all the time for a variety of
vaccinations
we've got to shape people at this point
and say come on now
we tried voluntary you know we could not
have been more
kind and compassionate as a country free
testing
everywhere you turn incentives friendly
warm embrace the voluntary phase
is over we can keep doing those things
i'm not saying shut it down
i'm saying voluntary alone doesn't work
it's time for mandates
no you dirt bag no
we have individual choice in this
country okay we have rule of law
in this country and just because you say
the voluntary phase is over doesn't mean
that it's over now i know that as a
progressive you think that the
government is god and the government can
force everyone to do whatever they want
you also apparently think that you've
done this with kindness and compassion
that's what he said they've done it with
kindness and compassion this whole time
of course his governor andrew cuomo is
the one who killed all of those elderly
people by intentionally sending infected
covet patients back
into old age homes i know you guys all
know that story already the justice
department has decided that they're not
even going to look into it so cuomo is
going to get away with literally
murdering people
but what really is interesting about
that clip is that it really shows you
the mindset of a progressive and at this
point i would say when i say progressive
i mean basically a modern democrat a
progressive
a socialist a marxist communist they're
all the same things they all want
government to do everything so what he's
saying
is we were really nice about it we were
really really really really nice
you didn't do what we wanted okay and
because you didn't do what we wanted
voluntary is over now we're going to
mandate it now
what are you going to do you're going to
are you going to literally send cops
and and soldiers into high rises and
grab people
out of their beds and force them to get
injected with a vaccine that
at the moment we're now seeing doesn't
work as effectively as
it was sold to us two months ago which
is why they're putting the vaccine
mandate back here in los angeles and in
dc
and it's probably gonna roll around
throughout the country because these
people
just want power he is a maniac
who just wants power we're gonna have to
shake people that's what he said we're
going to shake people and that made me
think of something
so we put together a little edit
thinking
of shaking people we've got to shape
people at this point
and say come on now
calm down i'll get back to your seat
i'll take care of this calm down
calm down get a hug oh do you want
another phone
everything's right
come on come on that's some fine work
we're doing there shout out to connor
he's two feet away from me we're not
social
distancing right now he just did that
doctor you're wanted on the phone
that's airplane of course spectacular
although as you guys know
i would say the peak of those type of
movies
airplane was around 1977 or so 78 maybe
can we get a
year on that the peak of those movies
was 1989
naked gun and of course uh the doctor in
airplane
is also frank drebin in the naked gun
1980 airplane
interesting i thought it was 79 who knew
uh anyway
there is more craziness happening now in
dc
representative kat kamik she is a
congresswoman from florida she tweeted
this out it's it's absolutely amazing in
today's edition of pelosi's abuse of
power
capital police have been directed to
arrest
staff and visitors to comply with her
mask mandate for vaccinated individuals
for members they advise not arresting
but reporting members to saa for their
fair
failure to comply therefore effective
immediately to promote
good health and well-being of our
employees all
uscp personnel must wear a mask
at all times when in interior spaces
throughout
the capitol grounds if a visitor or
staff member fails to wear a mask after
a request is made to do so
the visitor or staff shall be denied
entry to the house office buildings or
house side of the u.s capitol
any person who fails to either comply or
leave the premises after being asked to
do so
would be subject to an arrest for
unlawful
entry let's put aside for a second the
visitors whatever they mean by visitors
but let's talk about the congress people
and the staff members who work in dc
these are people who have all been
vaccinated right like pretty much we
know that all of these people
have been vaccinated um we were told and
we
played the video yesterday and i tweeted
it out by joe biden about a month ago if
you get the vaccine you don't have to
wear a mask anymore so either
he's a liar spreading misinformation or
did they get new information now that is
possible right you can get more data as
time goes on
but did they not realize when he said
that that more information was going to
come
and that there would be the scary delta
variant
and that suddenly now as i talked to you
guys about yesterday there's this
data coming out of israel that was
analyzed by swedish scientists
and it turns out that the vaccine is
actually closer to 40 percent
effective in some cases instead of 95
effective
and now they're saying that pfizer is
saying that you're going to have to get
a booster shot
probably every few months as i said
yesterday why don't we just do this on a
monthly subscription basis it's very big
it could be like netflix or just
4.99 they'll just inject you with some
experimental medication
every month like is that really where
we're at what's even more interesting
about this is uh ben shapiro who
actually
is the guest on the reuben report this
week i hope you've been watching the
clips
uh he tweeted this it's from a
washington post article it's actually
quite extraordinary so here's ben's
commentary first no biggie
just the cdc and nih admitting they have
no
evidence of the recommendation they're
making regarding
masking the vaccinated and now here's
the actual quote from fauci in
washington post
but fauci noted there is not yet
clinical data
on what the high viral loads mean in
terms of disease transmission
you can make a reasonable assumption
that vaccinated people can transmit the
virus
just like unvaccinated people can fouchy
said
do you guys see what a spectacular turn
of events this is
a few weeks ago if if fauci had said oh
we want you to all get vaccinated we're
going to make it free for everybody we
really want everybody to do it
you won't have to wear masks and
everything else but you know it is
possible
that you'll still be spreading covid you
might not only get coveted but you still
might be spreading covet we don't have a
freaking clue
that in essence is what he is saying now
and he's also
talking about the third dose take a look
certainly they need to listen to the cdc
and the fda
the nation's top infectious disease
expert is saying listen to the cdc
and not pfizer when it comes to needing
a vaccine booster
on friday this is what dr anthony fauci
told cnn about a phone call he received
from the head of pfizer
the ceo who's a really good guy got on
the phone with me last night and
apologized
that they came out with that
recommendation so there is no
not that apologize about the
recommendation apologize for not letting
us
know that he was going to do it ahead of
time this after pfizer announced on
thursday was applying for emergency fda
authorization for a booster shot to
protect against covet 19
a booster for americans to get as early
as six months
after their second dose pfizer set off
alarms when they released a statement
saying that the immunity from its
vaccine was waning
citing israeli health ministry data the
company said quote
vaccine efficacy in preventing both
infection and symptomatic disease has
declined
six months post-vaccination hours later
however the cdc
and the fda said fully vaccinated
americans do not
need an additional dose of vaccine at
this time
look if you're playing along at home
it's getting very hard to trust
anyone and i don't even want to sit here
and tell you to absolutely trust me i'm
trying to ingest
some of this information in real time
i'm trying to unpack it
and transmit it to you in a somewhat
honest way but i just don't know how you
can trust
these people at this point a year and a
half
from two weeks to flatten the curve
there's a reason we don't talk about the
curve anymore because
we did flatten it it did flatten there's
a reason that they don't tell you now is
they're telling us the delta variant
is killing all these people notice
they're not showing us numbers
and they're not sure they're telling oh
it went up 50
okay that could be we had three people
now we have five people it went up this
small person you know it seems like it's
a huge amount of
percentage-wise it's big but it's not a
ton of people they're not telling us
about the ages they're not telling about
the other diseases these people have
this is the thing it's always going to
be here guys covet is always going to be
here and the powers that be whatever
they are the governmental powers the
media powers the people that want to
keep you locked up and depressed and
everything else
they will always release another variant
they will always release something else
to scare you
and to keep you at home and to exercise
some psychotic level of control over you
and in most cases
they will not be abiding by those very
things themselves you all know the
endless amount of hypocritical
things that these democratic governors
have done and speaking of the biggest
hypocrite
of all well gavin newsom who as you know
is uh in the middle of this recall elect
elder.com
uh well it turned out that his son
you're not gonna believe it guys
his son while he's telling everybody to
mask up again
in social distance and everything else
his son's been at basketball camp and
they weren't
wearing masks at basketball camp and
some pictures leaked and now gavin is
very upset that the picture is leaked
and listen to
listen just really listen carefully it's
about a 20 second video listen to the
very obvious lie that he drops here
okay take a listen you want to come
after me come after me
and don't come after nine and ten year
olds you know
uh he was there for one day they said
they want to take a picture they took
off the mask hit a mask in his hand
and they're attacking and weaponizing my
son i watched network news last night
and they're weaponizing my son he was
sitting there crying with me last night
you want to come after me come after me
you did nothing wrong
we pulled them out of that camp
basketball camp you want to come after
me come after me not my kids
all right first off did you catch the
extraordinary lie at the end there
he did nothing wrong we pulled him out
of the camp
but if he did nothing wrong why would
you pull him out of the camp
was he playing basketball with the mask
gavin and by the way i'm not coming
after your son
i don't care about your son uh i have no
intention of attacking a child
you are an evil authoritarian douchebag
and you're playing the victim now this
is so
exactly what progressives do with
everything he didn't
believe that his family or his son
should abide by the rules that he wants
for everyone else much like him keeping
his wineries open
when he was closing everybody else's and
eating at french laundry and all of that
stuff
then his son is at this camp and then
people take a picture of it and i
guarantee
you his son was not playing basketball
with a mask on okay
so then they take a picture it gets
leaked then he pretends that anyone's
attacking his son
nobody zero zero zero nobody's attacking
his son but then he
is a tough guy okay attack me attack me
all right newsome i'm here i'm one of
your constituent constituents i'm
attacking you
you're awful i cannot wait till you're
recalled
and if you're not recalled i'm probably
leaving all right there you go so now
you have extra incentive
to run hard because i know you don't
want me here even though i have several
businesses here and i provide
to the economy and i'm a pretty decent
citizen i know you don't want people
like me you just want mindless drones so
that's probably what you're ha what
you'll have
however i do think that my friend larry
elder has a chance elect elder
dot com elect elder dot com elect elder
dot com but look that fake
tough guy he's such a fake tough guy
come after me okay
you want to have a debate you are
welcome on this show i might we
you we'll reach out to his people today
i mean we've done it before we will
reach out to his people today
i got a busy day ahead of me i'm about
to go off the grid i will do a live
uncensored no notes interview with you
today you dick uh
speaking
i i'm going off the grid soon you know
cut me some slack over here you know
we're ending in a blaze of glory you
know what i mean like all of my
frustration with these people it's
really just like i can see the
off-the-grid moment here the calendar is
going this way and it's like
they're getting crazier and crazier and
it's like man and then i disappear and
then i come back and i'm refreshed and
i'm you know
ready to roll uh elizabeth warren
elizabeth warren you know this is the
fake native american okay this is a
woman who pretended
pretended that she was a native american
to get
a job as a professor while she calls
everybody else racist
i mean that's pretty much the most
racist thing you could possibly do
because not only are you getting a job
that you really don't deserve if you
believe in that identity politics stuff
you're actually stopping a native
american person from
getting that very job that you took
white lady
well she is coming out swinging
for gavin newsom and listen to her ad
that she's putting
out for old gavin and yeah she's a
democrat she's a progressive
so it's full of lies here's the deal
with the recall of gavin newsom
we've seen trump republicans across the
country
attacking election results and the right
to vote
now they're coming to grab power in
california
abusing the recall process and costing
taxpayers millions here's how we stop
them
every californian will get a mail-in
ballot for the september 14th election
vote no to protect california and our
democracy
stop the republican recall ugh
awful they're just nauseating i need to
start taking imodium before the show i
think
maybe that would be a good idea these
people are just absolutely horrible
first off
it's the trump republicans of course
that are causing the recall this is very
much in line with what bernie
has been saying in aoc and the rest of
them these are evil right wingers the
implication is of course these are
racist
people somehow uh even though gavin
newsom's white and the guy who that
is going to replace him is black but
putting that aside for a moment that
they're all evil and they're it's
republicans doing this i just want to
say this again i've been to so many of
the rallies
about opening up this state the people
that are at the rallies
it's not even that they're not
republicans they're not even they're not
democrats they're not political people
for the most part they're just
regular people restauranteurs small
business people
everyone hates gavin that should be the
name of the sitcom
you've got to go i don't care where you
go but you can't stay here
um so of course she lies that these are
trump republicans
calling for the recall so she's saying
basically that 1.7 million trump
republicans in california
sign that recall thing to make it happen
okay so that that's just a lie
she says of course that they're
attacking elections which this is
completely
congruent with everything else that
these ridiculous people are saying
attacking elections yes
we're attacking elections by using the
electoral process by using
the constitutional process of recalling
these people we have
these systems put into place so that
when we have
really horrific authoritarian governors
we
can get rid of them by the way it's not
in the uh too distant future that
california did this california before i
lived here
had a recall of gray davis and remember
arnold schwarzenegger i'll be back it's
not
otuma he became the governor okay so
these things have happened in the past
was it trump republicans that did it
then
that was pre-trump but trump's like a
time machine for these people anything
can happen with trump
um so attacking elections i mean look
again you guys know all this stuff
that all of these election bills georgia
texas
everywhere that they're doing these
election bills it's about voter id
it's about paper trails it's about video
cameras when people are
counting it's to secure elections it is
these
clownish buffoons who are trying to
destroy
the election process uh she also says
they're abusing the recall process well
no they're just not i think i
illustrated that
already and also just is there anyone
more inauthentic
than than elizabeth warren remember i'm
going to get me a beer
and then she walks off camera on that
little live stream and that will never
cease to amaze me like really
i think sociologists and psychologists
probably anthropologists years from now
should all
study how a billionaire
orange man from new york was more
authentic than every single one of the
people who hated him
it's just absolutely incredible
absolutely incredible but speaking of
the people who hate him
the mayor of dc muriel
bowser has been one of the prime people
attacking the police
uh calling the country racist all of the
usual stuff
and then of course what happened in d.c
a lot of crime a lot of murder
a lot of bad stuff have you been to
baltimore it ain't pretty people
just the whole area is just a mess we've
got a quote here from the daily mail
d.c mayor muriel bowser announces plans
to add 170 police officers to the city's
force and requests
11 million dollars more funding to
recruit and train them amid rising
violence
last year the city council voted to
defund the police by 15 million
dc in 2020 saw homicides hit a 16-year
high and the trend is continuing in 2021
this month has seen high-profile
shootings that have angered
the community so she defunded them by 15
million now she wants 11
which i've never that's the most
financially responsible thing a
democrat's ever done
i don't know where she's making up that
four million um just absolutely insane
um i'm being told this is actually sort
of an interesting piece of this
she was sort of flip-flopping on the
defund thing she never really said she
was for it
or against it her city council voted to
defund it but she never really full in
and went
to defend it so i want to to defund so i
want to be clear on that
but we've got some statistics on uh what
the crime situation
in dc has been like this is from wusa9
in 2020 homicides in dc hit a 16-year
high if the current trends continue 2021
could be even deadlier dc police data
reports a 43
increase in homicides from the same time
last year with 2021 totaling 63
as of april 28th compared to 44 on this
date in 2020
2017 reported 34 homicides 2018 reported
40 homicides 2019
49 homicides 20 20 reported 44 homicides
2021 again is reporting 63
homicides the point is do you think
there might
be a connection between defunding the
police
getting police out of communities where
there is the most crime and then more
crime coming in
do you think if you have a place let's
try it this way let's say there's a
place
there's a lot of crime there there's a
lot of drugs there there's a lot of
homeless people there
and there's some police there right and
let's just say the police aren't good
they're not bad they're just completely
indifferent right not even going to take
sides you just got some average police
officers there
but there's a really bad place where
some bad stuff's happening right nobody
wants that to be
i want people to thrive and succeed and
live the best lives they can and
hopefully get out of poverty
and get out of living in crime rated
neighborhoods et cetera et cetera
well do you think that if you just took
those police officers out if you
defunded them and they had to move
resources elsewhere
do you think anything would get better
in those areas do you think the
criminals
in those areas the drug dealers the
criminals the pimps
all of the people that are doing the bad
stuff do you think they're gonna be like
guys the cops are gone i'm getting out
of the crime game
i'm gonna stop looting and breaking into
things and
doing the prostitution and selling the
crack and everything else
or do you think they might go ah vacuum
time to fill it with something and then
we're gonna do more crime
because we're not good people okay i'm
pretty sure you know what i did there
uh for the record we did just reach out
to gavin newsom's press secretary daniel
lopez i suspect we're not gonna hear
back and i know some of my language with
gavin has been
been a bit colorful but he does deserve
it and uh
and i and i actually do mean this i will
gladly interview him anytime
anywhere with with no notes we will just
sit down
and uh and talk it out
but he's a liar and he's a fraud and i
will gladly say that to his face
um okay guys big news so tomorrow i am
officially
going off the grid you know tomorrow's
the 30th uh the 31st is the last day of
the month but it's a saturday
so tomorrow night will be my official
last day
on the grid but we got a lot of big
stuff big stuff happening tomorrow so
first off
we posted already this morning a teaser
for the title of my new book at
reubenreport.locals.com so people are
guessing away
right there i will be doing a live
stream exclusively for our locals
members at 9 00 a.m pacific
12 p.m eastern every single person that
is a reuben report locals community
member that buys the book tomorrow will
get a signed
and numbered book plate numbered that's
the key part
no matter how many we sell i will sign
every single one and they will be
numbered exclusively
for you guys on locals then here as we
normally
do at 11 a.m pacific 2 p.m
eastern i'll be live for about two hours
i think we're gonna do a two-hour show
tomorrow
and every single book that is signed
that is purchased
tomorrow and we'll have links
accordingly obviously
i will sign a book plate for you guys
those will not be numbered so if you're
just watching on
the youtube we're not going to be
numbering them but i will sign them but
if you are a locals member i want to get
you one of those exclusive
signed and numbered copies and then i've
got a couple other
announcements to make uh we've got a lot
of stuff going on with locals i'm i'm
super psyched and
uh this is definitely going to be the
hardest year to get off the grid not
only because of the new stuff that i
talked about at the top of the show it's
like i could come back to anything the
aliens invaded
biden's head exploded like just anything
could possibly
be out there it seems like it would be
possible when i returned
but i have so much going on with locals
right now that it's going to be really
difficult to get off the grid
fully this time i may have to take a
couple business related phone calls in
the first few days but yeah no news
no current events no twitter no email no
facebook no instagram no pinterest no
nothing
for one month i do come back on
september 1st we will be doing that show
live uh we're doing that at corolla
studio right we're going to be doing
that show at corolla studio adam crowell
is going to walk me through a two-hour
live stream
on all the things that i missed
and uh what what are you telling me
there
what's that oh the back on the grid's
gonna be a little it's gonna be an hour
earlier than usual well this we're
giving you way advanced notice but on
september 1st our show will be at 10
a.m pacific 1 p.m eastern mark your
calendar now people okay
i know things get crazy over the summer
you could forget and then we'll be off
by an hour it would just be a nightmare
anyway i can't wait to debut the book
for you guys tomorrow and and i can't
wait to get off the grid and and just
although i'll obviously talk a little
bit more about this tomorrow uh i just
want to thank you
as always for just this incredible
amount of support that i continue to get
and all of the
these things that i'm doing and the
projects that i'm working on the book
the show
locals these things all continue to grow
and it's not just they're growing
because
you know i'm working hard and my team's
working hard it's because you guys
support us one way or another you know
what i mean like just one however
whether it's just because you watch or
you support us at locals
or you buy the book or whatever it's
like i'm living my dream
i am living my dream i truly am and i
truly will be for the
for the next month so that's
reubenreport.locals.com if you want a
signed and numbered copy live stream
early for the locals guys tomorrow
normal time here
and uh all right hectic day hope you had
a good
uh hope you enjoyed the show i i enjoyed
this show dude connor you enjoyed this
one
connor enjoyed it michael all right we
all feel good about it
guacamole on the chipotle for you guys
all right see you tomorrow